I don't know anyone I literally do not
know one person and I ask these three
guys does anyone in this room know one
person that's 81 still working a
full-time job obviously such people
exist but I don't know any they don't
know any Joe Biden is obviously not
capable of doing the job but don't and
by the way it's not purely because of
his age right it's the cognitive stuff
that is coming along with his age
because you could be 81 and super fit
and super aware and all of those those
things but we know that he is not do we
have some sort of compilation video of
that kind of thing my God we do I uh
um
anyway the best way to get something
done if you if it holds near and dear to
you that you uh um like to be able
to anyway from from uh uh Char excuse me
from Charlotte one another line line
going from in Florida down to Tampa of
Putin's CL
talk
yeah and and and Joan shengang I'm
pronounce
shanga 50, 159,000 billion dollars lad
America is a nation that can be defined
in a single word I was going to foot him
foot the idea that
um Los Angeles and the and um uh um what
am I doing here for two reasons one
to we haven't been able to communicate
it in a way that is uh um make me say
another way but the
nature
not solid meeting with um with
uh the uh they make a very good point
here's the
deal anyway they're running cover for
him we all know they're running cover
for for him it's just ridiculous cringe
Jean Pierre over at the White House
diversity hire cringe Jean Pierre she
will put Joe Biden against anybody
because he's strong and vital I would
put the president's stamina president's
wisdom ability to get this done on
behalf of of uh the American people
against anyone anyone on any day of the
week it's just meaningless dribble you
get
it